Lara Claridge author of Norman Rockwell
'life when did you get interested in
this artist in 1994-95 I went to
Cooperstown to the Baseball Hall of Fame
and with my children and I got very
bored at some point just looking at all
that the baseball memorabilia but in the
anteroom there's an there's an
exhibition of a good art on sport and
different sports subjects and there was
one that I I'd never seen before but it
I just it riveted my attention because
of the the striking color and and the
use of form and it was Norman Rockwell's
calling the game and it from that point
on I started thinking gee this is
something I don't know about because
this isn't what I what my image of
Norman Rockwell is what's your image of
a Norman Rockwell now ah that's an
interesting question as a person since
this is a biography um as a person a
highly intelligent and shrewd depressive
honorable deeply honorable very very
talented I would say first-rate artists
I guess I've encompassed both his
personality and my own judgement of his
art when did he die and how old was he
died 1978 he was 84 lived a long life
and was active in his art and is and a
very active a man until maybe 2 years
before his death what age was he when
this picture on the cover was taken well
his family lent me that picture and we
know none of us have been able to find
um you know the origins but we're
guessing it was his mid 20s he was in
his mid-20s what was he doing in his
mid-twenties he was the Playboy and he
was living a pretty a debauched life in
an open marriage and experimenting with
high society in New Rochelle New York
how many children did he have how many
times was he married three children
three marriages but the three children
went with the second marriage that's
interesting he was a high school dropout
and actually let's see at 16 at age 16
and never had any formal education after
that
and he married three schoolteachers not
that's not very difficult that seemed to
me to see a kind of fulfilling of
something that he valued and they read
to him one of the requirements that
seems of marriage for him was that his
wife read aloud a great novels while he
painted and the first marriage is this
one I referred to in the 1920s he
married 19 1916 and was n was divorced
in 1929 when the woman left him
precipitously for a handsome pilot and
it what's funny about that or
interesting about it is he almost denied
the marriage ever happened in spite of
the fact that it was 14 it was a 14 year
long marriage just his three sons found
out about it only in the 40s when they
read an article in The New Yorker about
his life he'd never bothered and when
they can phoned him he said oh I didn't
think it was important so which is that
it's a very strong psychological defense
of Rockwell's denial just or repression
we'll come back to that but I want to
show some of the art to Jeff in the book
what is this painting right here the
triple self portrait what she did in
1960 and was it's fascinating because of
its um its geniality its but at the same
time a real kind of what some people
would call a postmodern spin where he's
pretending to he's painting himself but
ironically mark a gently mocking himself
if you can see the actual black and
white on the canvas is a younger more
handsome man he's looking however in the
mirror as if he's copying what he's
seeing and did the image that's
reflected back in that mirror to add yet
another layer of ambiguity is okay that
the eyes are whited out what's that who
are those folks up in the right-hand
corner there's Rembrandt these are
self-portrait senate's it's important a
self-portrait of Rembrandt do not a
self-portrait but a painting by Picasso
that implies self portraiture and a
complicated relationship the women in
his life so Rocco was situating himself
mr. modest among these greats as he
himself attempted the self-portrait and
and admit it he didn't know who he was
to some extent where can you see that
that painting of that's a self-portrait
in the Norman Rockwell Museum in
Stockbridge Massachusetts which is a
wonderful it's a wonderful building the
architect Robert AM Stern designed it
and has an excellent collection due
largely to the inside of his last of his
third wife and foresight and about I
guess from here it's probably about a
seven hour drive from Washington DC you
point out in your book that in the old
museum or whatever the art gallery that
he had there on the Main Street in
Stockbridge he got about 5,000 visitors
a year and the new one has a hundred
thousand a year yes and the end
apparently going up the figures going up
every year
how did Steven Spielberg get into this
I've heard two different stories but the
one I credit I I think more comfortably
Spielberg was in town and at the Red
Lion Inn and someone went up to him
involved with the museum and said uh
we've heard you like Rockwell and we're
raising money for a new museum and would
love for you to be involved and arranged
meetings then it went from there
Spielberg does have a longtime affection
for Rockwell also have this painting
that you see a lot of where is it
located now what is it and when did we
see it in what publication well this is
an extraordinary painting that was done
late what's interesting to me is late in
his career in life Rockwell was in his I
would have been in his 70s just about by
now the problem we all live with it's a
representation of the of Ruby Bridges
having to go to school when when the
south of spaying deseg desegregated and
that that painting is now at the museum
also but what I it was done for Look
magazine but what I find extraordinary
is that it represents this very strong
liberal political desire to paint what
was happening in the world
that that Rockwell was willing to go in
that direction fairly late for an artist
me to start a very new direction in his
work you point out in your book that he
voted for Norman Thomas
yes socialist candidate in 1948 was he
very political himself uh no well he was
vociferous and in announcing to everyone
around him that he was not a political
man and that was to get out of all the
different requests to endorse so-and-so
ort and also he didn't want to alienate
his his audience by saying they were
saying the wrong choice the wrong person
but um you know that question interests
me what it means to be political he was
not overtly political he was however a
man of very deep convictions and and I
so so my own answer would be at heart
yes his children his three sons would
quickly say to me but don't forget he
didn't he was a validly a political
except for occasional endorsements he
loved Ike the first for the first term
and then afterwards he said he had been
a little disappointed in the second time
he disliked Nixon so he would make those
kinds of statements
sotto voce or to friends but that was
about it you point out in the book that
at one point he had a meeting a dinner
with eisenhower generalized now yes
where was that
and what impact did that have on him
well I he came to he was invited to it
what he called a stag dinner that
apparently President Eisenhower gave two
together to get a little bit of freedom
or free room to to be himself with many
liked and he after let's say after
Rockwell painted his portrait and the
two hit it off then sometime later
Rockwell got an invitation in the mail
to one of these stag dinners in
Washington and he came he enjoyed it
immensely and spoke about fondly in
years afterwards but what's what's
interesting to me is he was so nervous
and and by this time he was well
established and well-loved and certainly
a cosmopolitan and a world traveler but
he had to take tranquilizers to get
through the dinner and and he was
wearing his tuxedo didn't fit and
nothing was right so I I've always taken
that as I saw all of this as a sign that
he deeply respected Eisenhower to care
that much for for his opinion of how
Rockwell conducted himself or looked
during that dinner this painting of
Willie Gillis in church 1942 yes during
World War two Rockwell was was very
interested in providing well to the war
effort of what we would call wartime
propaganda pictures and and that's not
necessarily a pejorative and it was just
used descriptively at the time he had
been a bit young to participate in world
war ii and also there were illustrators
who they were just ahead of him this is
you know James Montgomery Flagg and
blind Decker so at this time it was
Rockwell's turn is how he saw it and
what I find interesting about the Willie
Gillis picture that one particular he
did 11 Oh Willie Gillis pictures and his
take instead of showing the glamorous
handsome man that line Decker used for
World War one he showed this kind of
every every boy next door the shock of
red hair in this case neatly combed and
in this picture sitting sombrely in
church as if we don't know if he's
attending a funeral or if this is simply
a wartime church service but there's a
quietness about it that's one of
Rockwell's attempts to convey the
seriousness of war you say though when
he was asked by the Marines to do some
work in Vietnam he said no why well that
was during the Vietnam War and he he
never regretted supporting and
contributing so heavily to World War two
to the World War two cause and he was a
major raiser of money for the office of
War Information the Treasury Department
but and by the Vietnam War not only had
he married someone who brought out his
most liberal tendencies a New England
schoolteacher but he himself was was so
anti violence it had been all his life
all his life that the ambivalence
that many people that he trusted felt
towards the Vietnam War gave him pause
so that by the time he had to confront
whether he was willing to contribute to
the wartime propaganda pictorial wartime
propaganda for that war he wasn't
convinced it was the right thing so
finally because he was in the end a very
honorable person on he just said I I'm
I'm not the right man for this when was
he the most popular I guess the 1950s
although I say that was some hesitation
because what surprised me in the
research for this book was how popular
from the beginning of his career I'm
talking by 1920 when he was only 26
years old he had he had made his fortune
or was certainly on the way to making it
he was well known the press on him is
voluminous so this is a man who was
famous throughout the first well
throughout a good four decades you have
this painting that says in the cut line
that was 1916 yes yes can you imagine
that at age 20 barely maybe he's even
nineteen he did his first cover for The
Saturday Evening Post the first of what
would be 322 and that which is an
extraordinary feat that was the plum
assignment to get the cover of Saturday
evening posts then why the Saturday
Evening Post and you know it's now still
around and it's I think they even still
call it the Curtis publishing company
based in Indianapolis but it's a monthly
and it doesn't have anything close to
the circulation it used to here
well you mean why did he choose the post
or why was it so bored and what happened
to that what happened to the you know at
what time was it a prominent magazines
right and what happened to around the
time that Rockwell was born in 1896 the
post had it had been struggling and it
actually started out as Benjamin
Franklin's Gazette Pennsylvania Gazette
back in the 1700s and at this point when
Rocco was born it was struggling for its
very existence and Curtis Cyrus Curtis
brought in someone else
George Horace Laura Moore who took it
over and revitalized it where was it
based it was based in Philadelphia in
Philadelphia at this point
so about it's important because it's
about 100 miles away from where Rockwell
was born and growing up in New York City
by the way he was a new york city boy
which many people don't realize this was
going on and the post started it tried
to combine a kind of urbanism with a
real solid this is what it means to be
American and George horse Lorimer saw as
his mandate the idea of unifying an
America that was on at that point it's
70 per turn the century 70 percent of
the children in New York City had
foreign-born parents so which is an
extraordinary figure so Lorimer saw
believed and some people later accused
him of isolationism as a result that we
ought to have a magazine that showed us
what it was to unify and be a a national
consciousness it wasn't that long after
the Civil War don't forget when you
really think about it 300 in how many
covers turn it 22 how many I often was
at consecutive weeks
not often um I think the most heat ever
did in one year was 11 where they
controversy over hmm
I don't remember the covers ever being
controversial there that I remember that
the Civil War Pete that the civil war
excuse me the civil rights pieces in the
60s were on and and then he became he
actually helped out core which was
radical left a racial rights group in
New York City that was a bit
controversial but the post covers the
only thing I remember is when he would
do one there was one with a young girl
who you couldn't quite be sure she was a
girl or boy and he got a real overspill
of letters on not so much on that he
should have been clear about the gender
but that what was he doing making a girl
look so sloppy or what was he doing
making a boy look so connected to
girlish things which I find fascinating
how many biographies have been written
about Norman Rockwell in the
conventional sense of a kind of soup to
nuts biography this is the first one
there are several partial stories and he
wrote an autobiography in 1959 how did
you go about doing this
well when I became very serious about it
and realized I was determined this was a
life I wanted to pursue I wrote his
middle son Tom Rockwell and said could
we meet and expecting that this would be
a drawn-out year-long process because
often it is when you're trying to get
the family's cooperation and to my shock
I got an immediate response come up and
see me in Poughkeepsie New York so
what's he doing he's a writer of
children's books and um and his wife's
an illustrator they live on a farm
they've had for some years lovely why
did you write Tom and not Peter or
Jarvis somehow I had been told and I
don't remember how I knew but I'd been
told that he was the executor of the
estate so I knew he was the right person
how old is he now the three sons are in
their 60s all three of them but then six
years of each other so he anyway he had
me up to Poughkeepsie and it just
happened he when we sat there he said
I'll tell you that I've been waiting
I've decided we've decided the family
that now's a good time to kind of to be
honest to be open and do you use
footnotes and I said I was taken aback I
said what do you mean I'm a scholar of
course I and he said because we've had
people who wanted to do it and didn't
want to document or had you scholarship
and I said well of course and I thought
that was a very sweet question though
and he's that he's a highly intelligent
man in a kind of gentle way of saying so
he asked me to send him a copy of my
book that was then coming out and I did
and we talked some more and then the
three brothers had to talk and it wasn't
that that they had authorized it I
wouldn't write an authorized biography
anyway but I thought it would be a pain
yet um not giving it its due the subject
if I didn't have the family's
cooperation at all what about the other
two brothers where are they one's in
Rome he's a sculptor stone add stone
carver stone carver Peter the youngest
and then the oldest Jarvis is in Great
Barrington Massachusetts did you talk to
all three Oh time and time and time
again in fact it was wonderful I got to
go to Tuscany and spend part of a summer
with Peter
and his wife and I thought gee this is
one book that will keep me right in the
Northeast unfortunately I won't get to
travel but who wouldn't who would guess
and great variant Jarvis they were also
open to to meeting me wherever and
whenever I needed I think you mentioned
time time he had a journal of some kind
uh that he did or the Norman Rockwell
yes he did and um this was a little find
I one day I was going through one of the
boxes in the museum archives and it's a
room a large room that's just stocked
and with boxes and memorabilia some of
it has not been catalogued so I was
going through one of the boxes that
everybody thought had been filed
properly and there was a small old
journal that it turned out was
Rockwell's private diary from the 1930s
he had taken a camping trip and it was
this wonderful moment of discovery where
I called over the archivist Linda Poirot
and she was excited because she knows
just about everything and she hadn't
seen this and we went through it and
then she told one of the sons and he was
excited because it was just nice to read
an uncensored account that rockwell
clearly did not mean for public
consumption of what it was like for him
to go camping for six days when his two
young sons were back at home with his
wife and what he thought of but there
are other references to what either a
calendar or something where he would I
know like calendar it late in his life
yeah yes yes that was very good too at
almost at the end of when I was
finishing the biography Tom Rothwell
decided that to share with me the
calendars that his father had kept the
last few years of the last ten years of
his life and Rockwell would just jot
down things that had happened during the
day or things he was worried about or
what was coming up or what had happened
and it was unbelievably helpful to get a
sense of where his thinking was during
those last 10 years of his life to go
through it's actually at this point
there um I guess they were those little
pages you put on a Rolodex economy what
do you call it with its spiral and so
they had been taken off and each year
banded with you know with rubber band so
you can just kind of go through each
page where did you go to find things
Rockwell besides the sons well the
museum archives which is an unusual
resource usually when you're doing a
biography you have to go everywhere
for years to collect what they've
already collected which was so that was
lovely where is it that's in Stockbridge
at the Museum uh and then I also went on
I just tried to ferret out like
biographers do anybody who had any
connection with Rockwell or who had who
was close to someone who had been
Rockville's friend or associate because
so so for instance I met with somebody
who had been as often who had been his
housekeeper at the end of his life named
Virginia Lovelace a wonderful woman has
a farm house and and and what was
interesting to me is to watch her trust
unfold where over the years I stayed
with her often at the farmhouse and she
decided I was alright and she would
share more and more of a more intimate
nature give us some of the things that
you learned from her that are important
to the book all right this sounds so
trivial but it helped reassure me of
something I wondered about the third
marriage I hope this doesn't sound too
prairie aunt but the third marriage was
Rockwell was in his 60s and had lost his
wife two years before to an unexplained
death and it was very traumatic for him
and he was then the hot bachelor in town
and Stockbridge because you can imagine
the women who weren't married who were
pursuing him then I may ask you about
Stockbridge where is it in the world
Stockbridge is um is within 10 minutes
of the New York state line and it's in
Massachusetts and West End of
Massachusetts east and east from New
York obviously but I got east like
Boston in the Berkshires
yeah the birches absolutely what's it
like there on the surface it's a lovely
little New England small town
cosmetically attractive and all those
white-picket ways white white picket
fence ways full of intellectuals full of
artists very little obvious activity
that would sustain it financially and
yet quite a bit of wealth there
so um you have a picture in the book
it's some years ago is it still look
like this you know it does if you change
the cars update the cars to to the early
21st century that's pretty much what it
looks like you say Norman Rockwell's
looking out through that big picture
whatever yes what was that he had that
window puttin on he he he when he moved
to Stockbridge he actually had a studio
that was the studio and he created above
a butcher shop and he needed a lot of he
needed good Northern Lights so he had
the front knocked out in that glass put
in and he liked to just kind of look
over the town during the day and to see
what was going on to paint so now that
we see a little bit of the town go back
to the housekeeper and her name is
Virginia Lovelace and she she had her
husband or ex-husband had been an art
director at Austin Riggs at the Menil
that the the institution there for
mental um for treatment of mental
illness and Mary Rockwell second wife
had been treated there for 10 years and
Rockwell himself had started analysis
Theron therapy for his depression so she
knew a lot they'd socialized together
been at parties with Eric Erickson the
psychoanalyst and it hurt a lot so when
uh but but then the point is that when
when the second wife died and Rockwell
was about to remarry
he ended up choosing a schoolteacher who
had never been married she was in her
60s and who seemed quite prim and proper
and one of the sons told me that in fact
Rockwell had shared with him that he was
worried what their sexual life would be
after marriage he was just he was just
worried because he didn't know he said
it and so I asked Virginia I said you
were the housekeeper you lived with them
the last years of their lives what do
you think and she said well I'll think
about this very proper woman and so then
the next time I saw her she said I want
to share with you that I am sure that
the Rockwell has enjoyed a lovely
passionate and intimate relationship and
that kind of thing and she just told me
a few with substantiating details and
but the point being that I became
convinced that that what looked like
their happiness was on all levels so the
three sons and a housekeeper anybody
else that was close to him or understood
him very well well I mean so many I I
for instance one of my research
assistants got in touch with a woman who
ben-hur family had been friends with the
first wife's family back in the 20s
which was hard to get at because that's
you know you're going back there in time
and she wrote wonderful letters to me
about what people knew about that wife
about their life about what had happened
during certain situations so so that was
a personal contact someone else who
Robert barrage a man in Indiana um has
spent 30 years as a schoolteacher and he
spent 30 years every summer going around
the country researching Rockwell is just
his passion so before many of the people
were dead who did know Rockwell he had
gotten interviews and he shared a lot of
that information with me which was I
deeply appreciate what you've done what
towns you live in in India I want to say
Evanston is that interval to Evansville
right Evansville what's he done with all
of his material I don't know any and all
and and if you're listening Robert yeah
I wish you everybody wishes he would
tell us what he plans to do because
we're not sure nobody knows for sure how
the man is um in his only in his late
40s I think so he has I mean he started
this when he was an old when he was like
19 or 20 and what kind of material is
here well the material that most of us
are envious of is is the interviews he
conducted with people associated with
that first marriage because um they're
they're dead now that I think the
brother of the first wife he interviewed
yes Irene interviewed hottie and who was
a real character and who had lots to say
and so I wish I could have gotten to him
but the man had died by the time I was
around so those kinds of things though
that I envy a couple of more paintings
this one the card game up top it's
actually called a bridge game where is
that from well it it actually is on I I
would have to remind myself but I
believe it's still in the collection at
the Museum uh since Saturday Evening
Post cover at one point right but the
way that worked is the paintings the
paintings themselves were usually
returned to Rockwell at least after a
certain date and 1948 fight that he
probably did get that one back but in
any event the the point of that painting
was to show to experiment with
perspective and it was important because
he had been so umbilical in his work
even and he lagged behind other
illustrators in doing that but this this
particular painting shows you what he
gained by doing that by giving in
finally because he could take he could
take pictures and then paint from them
from perspectives and angles he just
couldn't get if he was painting live how
big a paintings actually you say there
one thing they were 38 inches by 24
inches and all these in your book on
display there at the know dr. Parker uh
no not all of them because occasionally
for instance there was a gorgeous series
of paintings he did the 1920s that were
really done as ads for Edison Mazda but
at this time people like Maxfield
Parrish we're doing that he and Rockwell
we're doing these ads to show light as a
new the importance of light of electric
light and their beautiful paintings that
stand on their own as art but the
General Electric owns that whole series
for instance of 20 paintings what book
is this for you well depends upon how
you count which life and my life is an
academic if I count that this would be
my fourth book if if as writing for a
public that's not just in the in the
academies that would be my second where
were you an academic or anything are you
still doing no I'm not still doing it
the US Naval Academy I finished my PhD
in 86 I think it was and taught there
for 10 or 11 years as a professor of
English very enjoyably why the Academy
let's see at the time the dictates of my
husband entered into it and to where he
needed to be in Washington and so the
job offers I got I had to kind of think
what what would go best and I was very
happy to get that particular job offer
because the faculty there has a good
reputation where did you grow up
Clearwater Florida near the beach how
long did you stay there
mmm I grew up there till I would stay
till I was 18 18 or 19 I'm a Florida
girl and then went to college were
Florida State my undergraduate degree
and then ended up doing my PhD back here
at University of Maryland
what's your PhD in British romanticism
and literary theory of 20th century
philosophy for lit crit now is this book
the second book for commercial
consumption
yes it is the second one I did on a
biography of an art deco painter Tamara
de Lempicka and a life of deco and
decadence before this one and she's kind
of the opposite extreme you know the
glitz and glitter and glamour what was
the hardest thing about this book
deciding what my attitude was towards
Rockwell both as a person and a painter
I kept I've a slated I started being
dubious I mean I started out I was
somewhat dubious then I had this kind of
Epiphany where I so appreciated him it
was a love affair love fest and then I
went to the other extreme again and then
I had to step back and say wait a minute
you know what's the proper attitude
towards one subject as a biographer and
how can I best serve him and the project
what caused the fluctuation I think it's
something I want to say it's something
in his personality because he did it
with his kids he did it with anybody who
got very close to him he was a master at
creating desire and I would even use the
word manipulating that relationship so
that he invites proximity and intimacy
and you get close and then you realize
that that's as far as it's going to be
allowed and so then there's this kind of
coldness and I think that that it took
me a while to understand that dynamic
even though his oldest son had been
expressing that to me in different words
you know at least four or five visits
for four or five visits worth he kept
talking about that when I would say tell
me what it's like growing up he tried to
say that and I you know and I'd go away
disgusted saying come on you're selling
like a victim and this was a good father
in ink and then then I'd go back the
next time and say so you were a real
victim aid say no no I mean I wouldn't
say that so I think
the dynamic and Rocco's personality that
why did you get this from and who's the
oldest son
Jarvis why did you get it from Jarvis
and not the other two well that's an
interesting question to all the three
sons are so different in personalities I
mean more even I think that most
siblings were and Jarvis is the oldest
um had a particularly I think vexed
relationship with his parents probably
played out a lot of what Rockwell played
out with his parents and so forth you
know it's all kind of fell upon the
firstborn son talk about Jarvis year is
a photograph of him here and what was
that where was that tell you that was in
one of Rockwell Studios when he was
using one of his children Jarvis in this
case as a model he did this often that
the kids modeled for him and he posed if
you see he would show the pose he wanted
for the model to take he was a great ham
actor it's always said he wanted to be
an actor if that had been given him as a
choice
so Jarvis was modeling for him and when
did he when do you think he began to see
a problem with his father
early on he says he says one of his
strongest memories is when he was seven
years old and he and his father were
walking around a reservoir and he
thought at that point that his father
was going to open up to him I find this
a little hard to believe that it's Evan
this kind of thing would be taking place
but but Jarvis where's that that he's
correct on this and that is as they got
but they were walking around the
reservoir and just as he felt his
father's start to open up whatever that
means he pulled back and Jarvis says he
realized at that moment that it was
never going to be different what about
the other two sons what kind of
relationships are they in youngest Peter
I think was was the closest to his
mother you know the baby and his mother
was spending the Atlanta nan him and so
I in one sense that probably the least
complicated relationship with his father
I think they were friends and not
particularly close but the middle son
Tom my guess would be was the closest to
Rockwell and was the most like him he
was a writer
and he was his father asked him to help
him with the autobiography and and just
being around him the carrot that I get
the sense of the humor and the irony
which was very much part of Norman
Rockwell's humor sense of humor
and the kind of mind I just I think that
Tom might have been the closest of the
three was it difficult or expensive to
get the rights for a lot of the
paintings that you have in your book
well it was not difficult or expensive
because the vast majority of them are
copyrighted by the family in other words
they the family was very generous about
cooperating and so it was not a problem
it would have been a problem I think to
get I I didn't use covers from The
Saturday Evening Post as covers if you
notice the logos aren't there on I use
the the artwork the paintings that I
understands a different issue
that The Saturday Evening Post is not as
forthcoming we're looking at some of the
paintings on here what's the black and
white at the bottom I was a story
illustration that I found fascinating
because it was I think it preceded by
just a year or so the movie Wizard of Oz
and if you notice if you know that movie
at all went the awakening scene where
Dorothy is back at our aunts and uncles
the Tin Man and scarecrow that I think
that that movie took those those
personalities directly from this
painting if you can actually match them
the Tin Man and the Scarecrow and so
forth but it was for a story I think
what is it the peach it depends upon
what title it was given when I it was
used different time speech young peach
what about the one right above that were
the woman sitting on the bench yeah
again another story illustration that
was early in Rockwell's career and I
thought a beautifully painted I you know
the oils and that the color the tonal
variation there as well as the dramatic
use of space I thought was a
particularly nice example of those those
values and then up top there is the
checkers game yeah that's actually
Jarvis's favorite painting and I was
happy to hear that because it's possibly
mine too that painting is that the color
it is impossible to describe
it's the the values and saturation that
the yellowness of the yellow and the
Scarlet of the red as well as the folds
of the clout of the clown's
costume again an illustration an
illustration for magazine we had any
reaction from the family on the vote
they've read the introduction only and
and they all three were at work were
characteristic positive and Jarvis
though was wow I'm really interested in
this I can't wait to read this book and
I actually opened the book then the next
chapter with a story about him basically
so I hope he retains his enthusiasm once
he once he reads it but I did I got the
sense from the sons that they felt I'd
been fair I'm sure they don't agree with
all my assessments but she do get fairly
intimate yes I do and do you think
they'll have the same reaction when they
read all the gory details and what I
mean by that all the personal
relationships between the wives and all
that the reason I think they'll be
comfortable with it is we worked out a
lot of their discomfort in person I'm
not good as an interviewer I don't like
to go there either
you know there's a sense of it's very
easy to project yourself into the other
person's position and you say I wouldn't
how would I want somebody treating me um
but I said to them look if we don't
include this information I can't give a
fully fleshed portrait of your father
it won't be genuine and there's a way to
do it I think with a certain amount of
propriety which which I think I
maintained and they all I'm a knife l
Taz if I saw Tom Rockwell gulp visibly
at times and make himself talk but I
said there I think that I was careful
not to quote or attribute where I was
asked not to and so I think they'll be
comfortable with what I've said where do
these four paintings covers I guess of
The Saturday Evening Post fit in his
fame as he called himself an illustrator
but and what's the difference between
Ellis traitor and an artist boy the last
one is the subject of so many books and
uh heated debates so I'll start with the
first one the Four Freedoms which are
being
plastered reproductions of these all
over New York City right now it's
amazing and popping up in office
buildings and on computers the Four
Freedoms was a series of paintings that
rockwell did to illustrate Roosevelt's
on a combination the speech he gave to
Congress and January of 41 and then the
meeting he had with Churchill off of
Newfoundland and which resulted in the
Atlantic Charter the the ideas that were
promulgated in those two circumstances
became known as the Four Freedoms the
abstractions in the long run that
actually became I guess the backing to
the UN's charters to redeem speech
freedom of worship freedom from want and
freedom from fear yes yeah and what time
period well he painted those in of in
1942 and they were published beginning
in February of 1943 again to promote the
the war effort and actually the Treasury
Department made a hundred and thirty
three million dollars off of touring
those four paintings in 16 cities and
selling them selling war bonds with that
what the picture of one of them was on
the cover actually one of the war bonds
so but but it was interesting because
Rockwell was dying to do those he wanted
to do those more than anything and I
found a memo he went to a doctor once
and apparently during this period he was
told to have an operation and the memo
back to himself says I can't
and then he underlines the line this is
more important to me than anything I've
ever done and it it's more than the war
effort he was so idealistic he was so
pro living for those caught living that
kind of idealistic existence that this
was a chance he thought to put the big
ideas into concrete form where did he
live in his life well he grew up until
he was um really in high school in high
school or in June the last year of
junior high in New York City and in what
now is Harlem Morningside Heights and
but it was it was a nice lower middle
class neighborhood that he then
stigmatize later in life as a real
and the source of all violence which is
interesting the picture he is fairly
easy to pick out in this yes call there
on the lab who are the others the the
boy next to him standing behind him is
his um his very unattractive brother not
physically but emotionally Jarvis
Jerry as he was known and then his
father and mother wearing a seated
holding his holding the the boy's mother
Nancy his relationship to his mother
Nancy unpleasant in that um Victorian
she was a product of Victorian age and
that was replicated in their
relationship there she is
she was a Coquette who got what she
wanted that she passed on to Rockwell
who in spite of being mr. nice guy when
he wanted something definitely got it I
was told that again and again but she um
she she was spoiled and she also
suffered from depression in a period
where people didn't weren't very good at
analyzing that I'm sure that influenced
the relationship negatively to but how
long in his life did she live and what
influence did she have on his family on
his early family life
no his late very late family life uh he
actually took care of her when her
husband died in 1933 and he took care of
her for another over 20 years
financially she often was she would come
she would alternate living with Rockwell
and his family or at least down the
street he would put her in some nice
apartment complex or living with cousins
in Rhode Island there they are again
1911 where were they then in 1911 they
would have been in Mamaroneck in
Mamaroneck New York they moved to the
suburbs of New York City where Rockwell
was much happier Mamaroneck and then a
little bit later in New Rochelle on to
newer shell and in his adult life where
did he live well
basically three there were three major
periods he lived in New Rochelle until
1939 then he moved to Vermont
I cut a bucolic community in Vermont not
very far from the New York border though
once again and then he moved it was his
Arlington yes
and the picture you have in there of the
Arlington House this is which house is
this that's it's a gorgeous house that
had a twin next to it just like it a
kind of big old farmhouse that you went
through a very romantic little covered
bridge to get to and it's nt they
enjoyed it very much because you could
go tramping around the mountains behind
or visit the stream in front and go
swimming how long did he live there gee
I guess um 10 years at least in that
house see when we started you mentioned
that he had three wives and the first
wife was Irene married to her for 14
years which one is she in this picture I
can't quite understand I choose the one
to the far right with the hat on yeah
yeah looking at yes and all three boys
were born from Irene no the second
marriage from Mary from Mary Mary didn't
have any choice had no children
apparently I found out again very late
in the process but I found out from
someone who knew knew them that she
didn't she refused to have children and
he very much wanted to what happened to
the marriage well that's the marriage
that she ran off with embarrassed and
very much ran off with the brother of
good friends of theirs a New Rochelle so
should various socialites um that he
kind of had set him up they took hit
that the socialites took him to Europe
and while they were gone one of the
couple that the woman of the pair her
brother took Irene away and um for them
to I guess consummate their affair and
when Rockwell got back
Irene notified him she wanted a divorce
it was very public because he was so
well-known and humiliating what happened
to him then what do you do
he became he was very discouraged and
depressed and he left New Rochelle for a
couple months and moved back to New York
City the city he's supposedly hated so
much he kept returning to and holed up
in a hotel and gay parties and tried to
kind of find himself then went out to
California after about three months and
met and married within weeks his second
wife Mary Barstow up there the top left
and there she is
where they're seated and then finally
down
the bottom with their son Gervais right
with those happy pictures I it's hard to
find pictures like that of Rockwell
where he's relatively spontaneous
they're being forced to be a loose
physically how long were they married
well 30 years what happened to that
marriage she the last 10 years of their
marriage um actually more than that
maybe last 15 years she suffered from um
really aggravated depression that she
not only was hospitalized for she had to
have electric shock treatments and so
forth and at the end of the end of that
marriage she was not feeling well one
day and went up to take a nap and I was
only about 50 years old and he went up
to find her when she didn't wake up and
she was dead
apparently the cause was a heart attack
she'd had so much stress on her heart
from various reasons although around
town it was assumed she'd committed
suicide since she had been suicidal for
10 years and what year did she die uh
1959 August what impact did that have on
well there's actually a picture in there
that shows him just so gray and Haggard
he was lost I talked to people around
town a professional photographer there
on Clem Calla sure who said he used to
see him looking like death just death
walking around town you can see in the
mirror yes you can see his face there so
he's he actually looking into the mirror
yes and somebody took the picture and
there's a picture of her there on the
wall right up the top yes actually this
on the other side pagers same picture no
that's actually there's a slight
difference in years those are two
separate portraits bent over there on
the wall up there right he loved her
very much it was it was a strong
marriage yeah what impact did the her
death have on her three children by that
point uh they were on they're all out on
their own I had just gotten married or
at least eight you and so they were they
grieved but I think there's a sense and
I'm just reminding this from different
things they told me that they were
somewhat relieved because she had
suffered so much for so long with no
cure in sight what's this picture that's
a sad picture and in spite of its
occasion which is Tom Rockwell's
marriage Thomas
the young man to the far right and his
wife Gail and their parents are in the
foreground looking excited and happy and
then Mary who was at was receiving
electric shock treatments and had just
been kind of let out for the day she and
Norman are in the very back of the
picture looking out of place a bit which
apparently from weekend from stories
I've heard they she did feel very much
out of place at the time rather than
living in Arlington Vermont and then
what year did they get to Stockbridge
they got to Stockbridge um they they
spent a few years and around 1952-53
going back and forth a lot from
Stockbridge to to Arlington which is
just a couple hours travel for her
treatments and then they actually in
1954 moved to Stockbridge permanently
and which means that actually they had
been it was more like 14 years they had
lived in Arlington and so now they moved
to Stockbridge and that was kind of the
third major phase in my mind of his of
his geographical locations when did he
marry the second mary right the second
mary exactly whom will call molly that
was in 61 and let's see that's the
summer of 59 is when the second myriad
that mary rockwell the second wife died
and then he married Molly and two years
later how was that marriage very good it
was um it was a calm even-tempered
even-keeled marriage kind of the
opposite of what he had just had for 30
years I guess of course there were no
children and it was more a question I
think of real deep companionship she'd
had a very rich life herself as a single
woman schoolteacher and a private
academy a very bright woman and so she
saw this as an adventure being married
to a famous illustrator in that
photograph I just showed of the bicycles
you tell a story about the late years
where they used to go out and ride their
bicycles every day when they went you
actually had the number of miles 4.7
miles that precise that was Molly's
doing she measured things like that and
and kept up with it yes
did that every day and it kept them
healthy and Hardy until the end when a
couple there were a couple occasions
where Rockwell fell off his bike and
unexplained and he couldn't remember
afterwards what had happened one time
when they were in the Caribbeans and it
appears in retrospect he had many
strokes I mean little mi ni mini-strokes
and they tried to deny it for a long
time to the point where they also had a
routine of going out driving every
afternoon even though Molly was a
terrible driver and the townspeople kind
of knew when they'd be driving and
avoided that and watched out for them
and yet avoided them and finally all
this had to be given up as Rockwell kept
deteriorating and where's this picture
from there yeah the last one I had to
fight to include that because those who
loved him not his family we're friends
didn't want to show him like that that's
at the very end of his life on his on
what they call eskas escapade Oh which
is a little private area their house
that Molly had built that they could go
out on and escape the crowds that would
come that would go by the street and try
to gawk and he had put a tea cosy I
don't know if you can see in that
picture but on his head he put a tea
cosy even though he was the very end of
his life and often suffering from
dementia
he still had this incredible sense of
humor and he was kidding with Molly
who's in the front and the nurse and the
back and took the tea cozy and put it on
his head as a hat why why is he
important enough to have a biography
written by because too many people and
by the way in the world at large Europe
and the Middle East and the Far East as
well as as America he represents the
idea of America in the 20th century now
now what what people mean by that may be
very different from what he intended or
or how he's best used but he represents
a kind of there it is exactly saying
grace and that's a wonderful
illustration of the idea of America as
up as a tolerant generous capacious
country where you on the one hand the
right values obtain prayer sobriety on
the other hand room for people who may
not share those values
and who nonetheless can be invited in if
you notice that the corner of that
picture there actually slivers the
people there's somebody looking in
that's deliberately not fully captured
as if to invite the audience into that
painting 1951 on the other page is this
the art critic and his son didn't like
this no his son in fact I don't is none
of his sons like it because it's so
fraught with meaning the woman in the in
the portrait on the wall the model for
that was was Mary Rockwell when she was
ill with that depression their mother
their mother and the boy the art critic
himself is Jarvis he was used as the
model and then the group portrait on the
other side
the Dutch fathers represented a
tremendous kind of matrix of influences
in Rockwell's life both his ancestral
painterly antecedents Rembrandt halls
but also his own father who was very
interested in Dutch art why didn't they
like this because if you I don't know if
it shows up on that reproduction but the
art critic is shown as we as as
examining with a magnifying glass the
the bosom of the woman I mean supposedly
it's a it's a pin on the woman's gown
but but the the joke is that he's
leaning in to close that it's lacking in
decorum and and the the Dutch fathers
are laughing and mocked mock dismay so
somewhat on taboos were being violated
they're about mother-son relationships
so they ever told love the number of
total number of paintings he drew in his
life
no but a rough figure is that he did
over 4,000 pieces which would include
ads and portraits and Saturday Evening
Post covers how much was he worse when
he died not that much considering um he
had given away so many had given away so
many of his paintings because he they
hadn't become real marketable in terms
of money until late that a lot of his
best works had been given away
malee then tried to get on to get them
back for the museum
not for their own personal wealth so I
would say he was just an
upper-middle-class
a guy in terms of his end what he what
he left and in terms of an estate or
legacy you start off by saying the
Charles Dickens played a role in his
life yes how I think it cannot be
overstated and this may be my background
as a literature person in terms of my
own training but um he said again and
again how he was indebted to Charles
Dickens and people as they often did
with Rockwell self pronoun
pronouncements ignored that but if you
go back he his father read Dickens to
him aloud every night for a couple of
years when he was seven and eight and
learning to draw and he would actually
draw from the Dickens stories but even
more important is that his view of life
and he says this very quietly but
seriously a couple times in his
autobiography I was taught how to view
the world through Dickens including an
insatiable curiosity and I don't doubt
that absolutely and also Dickens helped
him give form to chaos
you know anti city pro pastoral ways to
act out or to give shape and form an
impose narrative form on some of his own
bogies I guess psychological both the
last painting you have in the book is
called the connoisseur right what's that
from 1962 yes and but that that
paintings gotten a lot of press lately
in terms of very good explication zuv it
but it is a wonderful example of what
what you just touched upon earlier what
rockwell could represent to this country
this tolerance he has a conservative
looking man standing there with his um
even then dated hat and cane so forth it
umbrella looking at a foe Jackson
Pollock there's something that that
America would have seen as oh it's that
abstract expressionist stuff and he it's
a way of he treats that abstract
expressionist piece very respectfully I
mean it's it's done fairly nicely and he
treats the conservative man respectfully
and he doesn't show us the face so
there's this amazing interplay of in a
museum of one type of sensibility versus
another
where do you live now in Brooklyn how
many children dear for four or at what
age various ages and I have to admit - I
inherited from my marriage - from my own
loins 16 year old 18 year old 24 year
old 27 year old and what your husband do
he was in the entertain in the music
industry and he is now with an Israeli
high tech company that's did that it's
it's American stations in New York City
and do you have another book in mind I
do
what is it I can't tell you why not
because I want to make 100% sure that
it's the one I should do is it a
biography
it is a biography but I'm trying to
think of an exciting new way to take the
idea of a biography not what edmund
morris did with dutch naissance
but but and expand it into being about
something else as well
how's that for oblique our guest has
been Laura Claridge and this is what her
book looks like Norman Rockwell a life
thank you very much thank you